님들, 젠슨왕이 삼성, 하이닉스
다음으로 반드시 필요하다고 말한 한국
종목 정체 뭔지 알고 있었어? 우리
같은 개미들은 삼성이랑 하이닉스만
바라보고 있었는데 이거 알고 있던
월가는 이미이 종목 죽고 있었어.
내가 뭔지 진짜 쉽게 정리해 왔으니까
딱 1분만 집중해 봐. 다들 지금
엔비디아가 삼성전자랑 하이닉스가 왜
필요한 거 같아? 당장 AI 친들
HBM이 부족하니까 물건 좀 달라고
매달리는 거잖아. 근데 지금
엔비디아가 필요하다고 보고 있는
종목이 하나 더 있어. 바로 HBM과
AI 칩이 완성되는 마지막 관문을
지키는 곳이지. 왜냐하면 AI 칩
하나 가격이 수천만 원인데 분량 하나
섞여 들어가면 기업 신뢰도가 박살나는
재앙이거든. 그래서 젠슨환 같은
CEO들은이 검사 과정에서만큼은
무조건 제일 확실한 놈을 쓰게 되어
있지.이 기업은 지금 세 가지에 소름
돋는 조건을 갖추고 있어. 첫 번째
조건은 미친 맞진율이야. 보통
제조업이 영업 이익률 10%만 넘겨도
대박이라고 하는데이 회사는 영업
이익률이 무려 40%를 넘나들고
있어. 심지어 최근 분기 순위익률은
43%까지 찍혔지. 이게 무슨
뜻이냐면 삼성이나 엔비디아 같은 거대
고객사도 좀 깎아 주세요라는 말을 못
꺼낸다는 거야. 대체할 물건이
없으니까 부르는게 값이 되는 거지.
인건비가 오르든 원자재가 오르든
가격에 다 정가해도 사갈 수밖에 없는
구조야. 두 번째 조건은 경쟁자가
들어올 수 없는 기술적 해자야.
반도체 칩이 작아질수록 검사 장비도
미세해져야 해. 일반적인 테스트 핀
크기가 0.3mm 정도인데이 회사는
이미 0.1mm 수준의 초미세 핀을
주력으로 찍어내고 있어. 경쟁사들이
흉내도 못내는 기술 격차를 벌려 놨기
때문에 반도체 미세 공정이
심화될수록이 회사의 독주 체제는 더
단단해질 수밖에 없어. 마지막 조건은
자본의 흐름이 증명하는 미래야.
지난주이 회사는 부산 지역 상장사 중
시가 총액 1위를 다시 탈아냈어.
장중 시가 총액이 5조 원을
터치하기도 했지. 단순히 기대감이
아니야. 올해 4분기에 대규모 공장
증설과 이전을 앞두고 있는데 기업이
공장을 늘린다는 건 앞으로 들어올
주문량이 감당 안 될 정도로 많다는
가장 확실한 신호야. 여의도
증권가에서도 최근 목표가를 8만
원으로 상향 조정하면서 온디바이스
AI 시대의 최대 수주로 지목했어.
스마트폰, 안경, 로봇 등 모든
기기에 AI가 들어가면 측동류가
다양해지고 당연히 새로운 테스트
소켓이 폭발적으로 필요해지니까. 지금
삼성, 하이닉스, 엔비디아, 퀄컴 등
글로벌 처녀의 고객사가 줄을 서서
사가는이 회사는 과연 어디일까? 바로
리노공업이야. 지금 여기 주가는 6만
원대인데 주가 수익 비율 PER이
30배가 넘으니까 비싸 보일 수
있어. 하지만 프로들은 이렇게
해석해.이 회사는 단순한 제조업이
아니라 R&D에 기생하는 기업이야.
반도체 경기가 안 좋아도 삼성과
엔비디아는 신제품 개발을 멈추지
않아. 오히려 불황일수록 더 많은
신제품을 연구하지. 리노 공업의
소켓은 바로 그 연구 개발 단계에서
필수적으로 쓰여. 즉 반도체 경기가
바닥을 쳐도 돈을 버는 구조를 갖고
있다는 거야. 이게 바로 시장이이
회사에 높은 프리미엄을 주는 진짜
이유야. 물론 알아야 할 리스크는
있어. PER이 30배가 넘는다는 건
이미 시장이이 회사 좋은 걸 알고
가격에 반영해 놨다는 뜻이야.
기대치가 높은만큼 실적이 조금만
삐끗해도 주가는 언제든 출렁일 수
있어. 결국 우리는 남들이 뉴스만
보고 우르를 몰려다닐 때. 진짜
부자들은 뒤에서 망할 수 없는 독점적
구조를 가진 기업을 조용히 지켜보고
있다는 거. 꼭 기억하고이 밖에도
유튜브 경제사냥꾼 멤버십은 초보자가
알기 쉽게 꼭 알아야 할 정보를
제공해 주고 있으니까 꼭 확인해 봐.
도움됐으면 좋아요 한 번씩 눌러주고
궁금한 종목은 댓글로 남겨져 다음
영상에서 전부 분석해 줄게. 이렇게
돈대는 정보들 매일 쉽게 정리해서
알려 줄게. 경제사냥꾼 구독과 좋아요
누르고 진짜 부자되자.